this video is brought to you by blinkist
the first hundred people to go to
blinkist.com forward slash biographics
will get one week to try it out for free
you'll also get 25
off the cost of full membership if you
want it more on them
they say that all great journeys begin
with a single step
likewise all mighty empires must start
somewhere
when one king's might and cunning match
his ambitions
egypt is undoubtedly one of the most
famous civilizations of the ancient
world it has given us
wonders like the pyramids of giza that
still stand today
over 4 000 years later while other
structures from that time
nothing but crumbled ruins and dust in
the wind
we have actually already covered the
fourth dynasty here on biographics the
dynasty that was responsible for many of
the landmarks that we associate with
ancient egypt but
then we thought why not go back even
further that is why today
we are starting at the very beginning as
we take a look at the first dynasty of
egypt
right off the bat let's start with our
standard ancient history disclaimer and
mention
that our knowledge of this time period
is sparse at best with
giant gaps in the middle in the case of
some pharaohs of the first dynasty we're
not even sure that they actually
existed while others might have been
individual rulers or
they might have been the same person
under different names some of the main
sources used by scholars to trace the
history of ancient egypt to back to its
roots include a steel called
the palermo stone a papyrus called the
turin kinglist
a giant temple wall inscription known as
the aberdos king list and
the writings of monito a priest and
historian who lived over 2500 years
later none of the sources are complete
and none of them are entirely reliable
and at some points they clearly
contradict each other therefore the
timeline of the first dynasty is filled
with
a lot of educated guesses rather than
cold hard
truths but we will bring it to you as
best we can
in prehistoric times egypt was divided
into two halves upper
and lower egypt although upper egypt was
in the south while lower egypt was up
north this was due to the strange
direction of the nile one of the few
rivers in the world that flows
north it coursed from the highlands in
the south and
traveled north forming the nile delta in
lower egypt where it drained
into the mediterranean sea each region
had its own king and unsurprisingly they
often fought with each other eventually
this led to the unification of the two
lands into a single egypt sometime
around 3100 bc thus launching a new era
known as the early dynastic period which
lasted until the beginning of the old
kingdom
about 400 years later however the
identity of the person responsible for
this unification is a matter of debate
we have two names narma and manny's
there are various ancient sources
that credit each of them with being the
triumphant conqueror and first pharaoh
of a united egypt for a while the
general belief among scholars was that
manys was the pharaoh while
nama was the name of the last king of
the previous period however
continued research and new discoveries
uncovered additional mentions for nama
as the unifier but not for many no
contemporary ones at least
it seemed that the sources who mentioned
many's all came thousands of years later
it was probably 19th century
egyptologist sir flinders petri who
first suggested that nama amenis might
be in fact the very same person
this would not have been unusual since
pharaoh's had multiple names and
although this has become the most
accepted viewpoint nowadays among
scholars
it's still not a certainty the best
evidence in favor of nama as the first
pharaoh
is a cosmetic artifact made out of
siltstone
known as the palette of narmer believed
to have been made during his lifetime or
soon after the palette identifies narma
by name and shows him wearing the
white crown of upper egypt or head jets
on one side and
the red crown of lower egypt or deshred
on the other the double crown would go
on to become a symbol of the unification
of the two lands as
the pharaohs who came later wore a
combined version of the two
called a patient we're going to go with
the most common stance that nama and
many's are the same person
and that he was the first pharaoh of
egypt his tomb was discovered over a
hundred years ago at the necropolis of
um el-kwab
near the sacred city of abidos as the
site of many ancient temples and the
resting place of the first pharaohs
abbado served a role similar to the
valley of the kings but the later
dynasties and was one of the most
significant cities from the early
history of egypt the other ones were
memphis which continued to play an
important role for thousands of years
and thinness which supposedly served as
the first capital of egypt
we say supposedly because we only know
of thinness from
ancient sources its ruins have yet to be
discovered the tomb of narma
is quite modest compared to what we
usually expect when we think of pharaohs
the giant pyramids of the fourth dynasty
were still a very long way away
the first pharaoh of egypt was buried in
a simple tomb that consisted only of two
pits dug into the ground and
lined with mud brick walls they were
covered with a rectangular flat-roofed
brick structure
called a moustaba
we're not sure for how long narma ruled
egypt but most sources indicate that it
was a lengthy reign according to meniso
who always referred to him as many's
he had a very long reign of 62 years and
was killed by an attacking hippopotamus
we also might know the name of his queen
consort
naith hotep her name which means nath is
satisfied would indicate that she came
from lower egypt since the goddess nath
was primarily worshipped there as nama
was from upper egypt it is highly
plausible that they married as another
symbolic unification of the two lands
when she died
hotep was buried in her own mastaba
which was actually a lot nicer
and bigger than nama's tomb because of
this the egyptologists who first
discovered it over 100 years ago
initially thought that it belonged to a
pharaoh in fact there are still some
scholars today who believe that nath
hotep might have had a short stint as
regent after her husband died
until her son came of age which if true
would make her the first woman
to rule over egypt either way the next
pharaoh was hor
aha presumably he was the son of narma
and niece hotep as
an inscription with his name was found
in his mother's tomb but
we do not know this for sure in fact
some ancient sources such as the palermo
stone name him as the first pharaoh
which is why certain scholars believe
that he was actually manny's the
one who unified upper and lower egypt in
this case nath hoteb would
have been his wife and mother to his
successor de ger who we'll talk about in
a bit
this is a plausible scenario but there
is some contradicting evidence as
egyptologists have uncovered multiple
inscriptions that
mention horaha's queen consort as a
woman
named benarib again we have very little
information about what happened during
this ancient reign one minor inscription
mentions that the pharaoh smited the
nubians in
one regnal year so presumably he led a
successful military expedition against
his neighbors he also turned memphis
into one of the most prominent cities of
his empire with
some even believing that he may have
founded it his tomb is located at um
near that of nama which is a further
indication that the two were father and
son
it appears that hor aha was the first
pharaoh to practice retainer sacrifices
meaning that his servants were slain and
entombed alongside him
so they could serve him in the afterlife
as well now we'll continue with the
ancient egyptians in just a moment but
first a quick break to today's video
sponsor blinkist how many times have you
seen a book and thought
that's really interesting i wonder if i
could read it in 14 minutes if you're
like me
happens all the time i mean reading is
great but i do have other stuff to do i
can't just sit down for three days in
the middle of the week and read a book
from cover to cover
fortunately there's blinkist which
condenses that meaty hardback you've
been staring down
into a quick summary like cliff notes
for adults with blinkist you can
read a book on your lunch break or
better yet do what i do and listen to a
book summary
like a podcast i walk to work every day
and so i pop in my headphones and i fire
up the blinkist app and by the time i've
reached the studio i've listened to a
whole
new book or at least the summary of the
most important parts
it's great for multitaskers and when
you're me the fact boy
you've got to cram in as many facts into
your day as possible blinkist has 14
million users and more than 3 000 titles
to peruse one that i've got on my list
right now is the innovators which is a
walter isaacson book he also wrote the
steve jobs biography which i really
enjoyed i haven't actually read this yet
probably listened to it on the way home
today 19 minutes for this one divided
into 13 blinks
definitely worth checking out and so if
you're interested in learning big ideas
in small packages head to blinkist.com
forward slash biographics but the first
100 people
will get to try out blinkist for free
you'll also get 25
off if you want the full membership
again seven day trial cancel at any time
blinkers.com forward slash biographics
and let's get back to egypt
who presumably was his son according to
the palermo stone his mother was named
ken thap one of
hor aha's royal wives but not his queen
consort
de ger's own queen console was probably
named nakatnayth based on an inscription
found inside the tomb at um el cuabe du
jour had a very long reign as pharaoh
and ether claimed it was 57 years which
might be a stretch but not by a lot
other ancient sources mentioned specific
regnal years of deja
and assuming they're correct the
reconstructed timeline of the first
dynasty suggests that he reigned for
around 41 years
frustratingly we don't know what he did
during all that time egypt was
far from the dominant power in the
region yet its strength was steadily
rising and
deja continued along the same economic
religious and social policies as the
previous pharaohs just like with his
predecessor there is an inscription of
de jure smiting someone
in this case it was the said jet someone
we are unfamiliar with but presumably
represented a nearby ancient people
that were conquered and absorbed by the
egyptians in their early history
there are more examples of human
sacrifice from deja's time most likely
done as part of the funerary ritual for
the pharaoh if the rulers of the later
dynasties considered the size and
grandeur of their pyramid to be a sign
of their own majesty
then for the pharaohs of the first
dynasty it must have been the number of
servants sacrificed in their home in de
jair's case over 300 people were buried
with the pharaoh in his tomb near
aberdos to serve him in the afterlife
this was a practice reserved mainly for
the early dynasties
the later ones all used shabti's tiny
figurines that symbolized the pharaoh's
retinue
instead of actual humans deja was
succeeded by dejete who is an even
bigger mystery to us than his father
assuming that they were related part of
that is due to his relatively short
reign which was around 10 years even
though
monito again ascribed him to a much
lengthier reign of 23 years
the reason scholars feel confident that
deje did not rule that long is because
an inscription on an ivory artifact
mentioned that he only participated in
one
sakhar festival which was held every six
to ten years
the other reason we don't know much
about the jet is because of a very poor
historical record even by the standards
of the first dynasty the part of the
palermo stone that includes his reign
is just missing scholars presumed that
he continued along the same lines as his
predecessors as governing over a
thriving egypt that was steadily
increasing in power his tomb is also
located in um el cuab and he was buried
with 174 servants for the afterlife much
more interesting
is the woman believed to have been his
queen consort named
manith she might have been the first
female pharaoh in history it is almost
certain that she served as region for
her son
den after gidet died but it is also
possible that she ruled in her own name
for a while this is based on a cylinder
seal found in dens 2 which includes one
of the earliest king lists in egypt it
names all of the pharaohs up to that
point in chronological order
nama horaha to jai dejet den
but it also names monith further
evidence is provided by mernith's tomb
it was quite large it was positioned
next to the tombs of dejet
and den and it included around 40
servants for the afterlife
in other words it looked like the tomb
of a pharaoh not just a queen consort
even if this did happen
aneath did not appear to rule for long
because her son den soon became the new
pharaoh since we're
unfamiliar with their customs we don't
know if mernith willingly gave up power
for her son or
whether she was somehow forced to do it
or if she died but we do know a lot more
about
den than any of the other pharaohs of
the first dynasty this is because
he had a long reign spanning at least
three decades and
because he is well attested to in the
historical record
it seems that den was a very competent
ruler probably even the best of the
first dynasty and
he introduced new policies that affected
all areas of egyptian life including
religion
art administration economy and
architecture he was the first pharaoh
depicted
wearing the pashend the double crown
that became one of the most powerful
symbols behind the union
of upper and lower egypt he was the
first to receive a throne name which was
empty in his case and the first shown
carrying the nakaka the flail which
symbolizes the pharaoh's authority
alongside the crook
his tomb of el-quab also stood out from
the others for starters it was the
largest and most opulent one of all but
it was also built differently compared
to the others it had a stairwell leading
down to the tomb entrance and
a massive burial chamber and was also
constructed using a granite floor and
other stone elements instead of just mud
bricks lastly
den took 136 servants with him in the
afterlife whose
burial sites were located all around his
tomb
following the reign of den it appears
that the first dynasty went on a steady
decline that eventually led to its
collapse
he was succeeded by anna jib who is
poorly attested in the historical record
he may have been dead
some but we have no evidence that points
to this conclusively
modern scholars are also fairly certain
that anejib had a short reign no longer
than 10 years even though the turin
kinglist credits him with
a highly improbable reign of 74 years
egyptologists also believed that anejib
took the throne when he was already
pretty
old which would make sense if den was
his father given that
he held the throne for anywhere from 30
to 50 years
we know a very few events from the
timeline of aneed
some cylinder seal impressions mentioned
the construction of
a new fortress and a royal residence it
also seems that the pharaoh had problems
with revolts in lower egypt which
continued into the reign of a successor
arguably the most notable thing about a
nedjib was
how bad and poorly constructed his tomb
was up until this point the royal tomb
seemed to get steadily bigger and better
as the
egyptians continuously improved their
royal funerary traditions at aberdos
this culminated with den who had the
nicest tomb of the first dynasty but
then went sharply in the opposite
direction with a nedjib who
had the worst one the starters it was
the smallest even smaller than that of
nama it measured 16.4 by 9 meters and
only consisted of two chambers and a
stairway granite was completely absent
this time and
the burial chamber was made entirely out
of wooden planks set directly in the
sand
64 burial sites were located nearby by
an egypt's servants
the tomb was done in a rush without much
concern but the question
is why was the lack of care somehow
indicative of how the egyptians felt
about the pharaoh and his reign was it a
sign of how his successor felt about him
or
was it simply done according to the
orders of an egypt himself who
simply wasn't that interested in having
a fancy royal
tomb we don't know the answer but
speaking of his success a nedjib was
followed by
simerica to probably rule egypt for
around eight and a half years
some ancient sources credit him with a
longer reign but the palermo stone
actually has an entry for
each of his regular years and his ninth
one is listed as the year of his death
sumarket
is the only fear of the first dynasty in
the situation so is the only one whose
reign we can establish
with a modicum of certainty
unfortunately even though scholars can
see entries for each regnal year the
palermo stone is too damaged to
actually read what the entries say so we
know little about smoking's reign
we know that it was troubled by revolts
like that of his predecessor but that's
about it
egyptologists have made a lot of
hullabaloo about sumercat's relationship
with an edgy which
may have been hostile initially they
speculated that suburket may have
usurped the throne from his predecessor
because
they found in his tomb artifacts
originally made for nedjib which
had his name scratched out and replaced
with sumerket furthermore samarket was
left off the sakara king list made
during the 20th dynasty
indicating that his descendants may have
wanted to forget him
this idea does not have a lot of support
anymore mainly because
it seemed that his immediate successes
recognized some marquette as
the rightful pharaoh and because other
rulers also took vessels belonging to
their predecessors and
replaced the names with their own summer
kit's tomb at um
was considerably nicer than the one
belonging to a nedjib it was much larger
about 29 by 31 meters and the burial
chamber was lined with bricks
67 additional tombs surrounded her for
his raw retinue the tomb had been so
saturated with aromatic oils that
even when it was excavated by flinders
petri almost five thousand years later
the fragrance still permeated throughout
the chamber
the last pharaoh of the first dynasty
was quoi sources
show that he had a long reign anetho
said 26 years but this is a rare
instance when modern scholars think that
he actually went too
low that is because they found
inscriptions which said the quoi
took part in two said festivals going by
tradition the first one is celebrated
after 30 years on the throne and all
subsequent ones are done
in three year increments therefore two
set festivals would suggest a reign of
at least 33 years
but no more than 36. despite his length
we know very little about what happened
back then and
we're not sure of the events which led
to the downfall of the first dynasty
what scholars believe is the most
plausible scenario involves some sort of
strife and disagreements following
quaar's death and
involving his heir maybe this was due to
all the revolts that occurred during his
predecessor's reigns as we do not know
how those were ultimately resolved there
is some
small evidence that suggests the
existence of two more mysterious figures
who
may have served as pharaohs briefly
during the first dynasty one of them is
called sneferka
the other is identified only as horus
bird
they're not present on any king's list
nor do they have tombs at abdos
scholars just found their names
inscribed on a few labels this indicates
that the ancient egyptians never
recognized them as true pharaohs and
this could be because they fought each
other in a war of succession and caused
the turmoil that ended the first dynasty
this conflict if it ever existed was
somehow resolved by a third person
named hotep sekhemwe who started the
second dynasty
like with most things from that time
period his relationship with the
pharaohs who came before him is unknown
but it did not appear to be hostile we
say this because it seems that it was
hot except kemwee who
completed the tomb of koa as his name
was found inscribed inside the chamber
there were only 26 additional burials
for servants this time a sign that this
practice of human sacrifices would
already falling out of favor with the
egyptians
we should mention at this point that the
division of ancient egypt into 32
dynasties was
done retroactively much later it was not
something contemporary to them
it was that dan menetha again who first
mentioned the divisions and
just a reminder he lived during the 3rd
century bc which was over 2500 years
after the first dynasty in some cases
the division was pretty clear when
one bloodline ended and another began
but in other cases the separation
between dynasty seemed
a bit more arbitrary it is entirely
possible that the egyptians who lived
during the second dynasty did not
consider themselves to be a part of a
different era
and the pharaohs did not see themselves
as starting a new line of succession
that being said we're going to stick
with the traditional division since it
is also used by modern scholars
more for convenience if not for accuracy
therefore we must bring the first
dynasty of egypt to an end
it was an obscure lineage one filled
with unknowns and uncertainties that are
unlikely to ever find an answer
even so it represented a landmark moment
in history which saw the birth
of one of the greatest and most enduring
civilizations
of the ancient world so i really hope
you enjoyed this video thank you again
to blinkist for sponsoring it there's a
link to them below
also please do hit that like button if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
subscribe
and thank you for watching